and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review Fifty
Shades of Grey oh my god this is a
greatest movie I've ever seen in my life
the parts my dominant let me watch a
dominant mistress am I allowed to tell
the good people spoilers you lie boilers
here's this woman named Anastasia Steele
who come on what's her real name come on
that's like saying I'm Cinderella
diamonds and she sent in as a substitute
to interview a man a Christian Grey and
he's like I imagine you're not a real
journalist no I work in a hardware store
it just something for my roommate when
your roommate have gotten another
journalist ourselves yes but they won't
be as quiet shy or inexperienced I find
those qualities attractive in you for
some reason and I find your lack of any
like my identity attractive for some
reason I invite you to join me in an
elevator shaft I'll be used as an
obvious metaphor for later okay
symbolism obvious so Christian Grey one
the most photographed and famous
millionaires in the world walks into a
hardware store without ever being
recognized in fact he walks into a lot
of places without being recognized he's
kind of like an internet celebrity that
way he had enough for rope duct tape and
zip ties oh isn't that cute he's a guy
on tumblr about to ask someone on a date
but then when I entered uh something
that Gracie's as incredibly dangerous
she gets drunk dude it's dangerous I
must be this guy's Evel Knievel and gray
is like stay there I'm gonna bring you
to a safe place
oh yeah where's that a dungeon where I
can tell you up and beat you oh well
that's sounds weak well so gray tells
her that he wants her to be his
submissive sexercise and anna is like i
can't agree to do this I know nothing
about you well yeah sex with me even
though you know nothing about me okay
but I still watch her to indulge his
fetish even though there's about a
million other people in the world who
would do so willingly and great it's
like you must sign this non-disclosure
agreement that you'll tell nobody that
we are dating and I'm gonna cross out
this part that says tell nobody have a
place it would tell everybody but you
will not get angry for some reason I
think that's fair wonderful but no way
you love me I'm sorry I don't do love
what the message is hire prostitute or
something because there's something that
trust me to you something the writers
obviously forgot to put in but
nevertheless it draws me emotionally to
you even though you just said you don't
get emotionally involved hey sorry baby
I'm just not a flowers and candy kind of
guy but you do seem to be a helicopter
and airplane and buying me cars kind of
guy those are two totally different
things
yeah one's a lot bigger don't question
me I'm complex so gray admits he was a
submissive when he was only 15 years old
and also admits he was born from a woman
who was a crack addict and if I turn to
meet his family while he also goes to
meet her family yet does not get
emotionally involved and Anna's lucky
you make no sense whatsoever of course I
don't I complex yeah I think I'm
confusing complex with inconsistent and
lazily written it's no more inconsistent
than you hating my gifts but still
taking them higher and not filling out
the paperwork but still being tied up in
spanked anyway well I know we're
inconsistent than going to a
relationship I clearly said what
happened of love and you're you casually
trying to get love out of it what can I
say we spawn from Twilight fan fiction
there's really no direction to go but
down let's just get the horny
middle-aged ladies the bondage that they
want okay
but Ana still wants to find out more
about him so she s in to confess why he
likes all this weird ass crap and Gray's
life I can't tell you it's too painful
yeah I know you seem to be a guy who's
tied into them but not this time
I'm complex but you confess to me all
that other difficult stuff you never
told anyone that was different at that
point I was at this little complex now I
met this limo complexified complex okay
then show me the pain you feel went
really yes don't hold back it's clearly
the only way no I think we clearly
establish I can tell you I'm just being
stubborn no I'm giving you permission to
pick the living crap out of me you're
sure you weren't talking to a sadist
here yes okay well I'm just gonna do
what I've always done to you except a
lot harder and I want you to count with
me
really that's it yeah for someone as
messed up as I am you think it'd be
worse but all right you have my
permission to do so Oh what are you
crazy but you're the one who wanted me
to your monster okay I will clearly not
do what you tell me directly to do the
next time you directly tell me to do it
you're a psychopath and a fiend and I
love you wait what say you love me back
yeah we've gone over this I'm not gonna
say that even though I confusingly go
back and forth between saying it and
everything but words made it more clear
what this relationship was a boat
what do you want to ring dr. Matt the
heads everything spelled out for you oh
wait there and I'm going away leaving
anything open for sequel books well can
you at least join me in the elevator for
Elena attempt at book ending the film of
course this ending makes no sense the
end so Fifty Shades of Grey was read
come fix even though we didn't really
see Fifty Shades of Grey it was more to
a jerk and a little less of a jerk and a
whole generation of women have been
introduced to a world of sex they never
even knew about now if you'll excuse me
I have one who's paying me quite well to
help her explore her kinky side Oh
Chester it's playtime
this is history bumsang bad days you got
bad guys oh come on these lashes really
hurt man come on bad day
quiet submissive oh oh but you miss my
happiness oh god I feel so empowered
you